[موسيقى]
ست طبقات وماضي حافل قد
يكون هذا مجرد أشهر معجنات بودابست ، لذا
فأنت مهتم بكعكة dvash حيث
أعتقد أن هذا صحيح ولمعرفة المزيد ،
هناك مكان واحد فقط للذهاب إليه ،
مقاهي بودابست هي أكاذيب جريئة في
قلب  العاصمة المجرية وتعمل
منذ مائة وستين
عامًا ، إنها حقيقية ، لذا فهي لا تبدو وكأنها
طاولة أو ثريا عمرها مائة عام ،
إنها أربعة عشر مائة
عام ، كعكة دوبيش ليست فقط
مفضلة آنا التي يجب أن أعترف بها كل أسبوع
أضعه  أحد تخصصات مطاعمها
هو Dovish Cake هي أشهر كعكة
في المجر ، تفرد
كعكة الدراويش هي بالطبع الكراميل في الأعلى
وهي ذات نوعية جيدة من
الشوكولاتة ، ومن المهم أن تحتوي على
ست طبقات بالتأكيد يمكنك الغش قليلاً
تعرف عليها ستة على أرملة مع الثمانية الأوائل
ستة حسنًا ، حسنًا ،
فلماذا الجنس يمكنك أن تسأل التنوع أو جيف
لماذا
ستسأل جوزيف دوبيش عن الألغاز وراء
كعكته قد يكون صعبًا؟
خبزه tioner لأول مرة في عام 1885
للمعرض الوطني المجري
وكان رائداً في ذلك الوقت
باستخدام الكراميل ولون
الكراميل الذي لم يستخدمه أحد من قبل بهذه
الطريقة كان استخدامه لزبدة الزبدة أيضًا
أولًا ، وكان هذان الابتكاران معًا
يعني  أن الكعكة بقيت طازجة لفترة
أطول مما سمح لها بشحنها
عبر القارة قام الحمائم بحراسة
وصفته بعناية في وقت مبكر ولكن عند تقاعده
شاركها مع أشهر المقاهي في بودابست
اليوم ، تقدم المقاهي
الهوائية حوالي 25000 شريحة من الدوبيش كل عام ولكن
هذه الأيام الكعكة لا  لا أسافر
بقدر ما كان
لدينا العديد من رسائل البريد الإلكتروني ، يرجى إرسال
كعكة الحمائم ولكننا نقول دائمًا إنني آسف
لست سعيدًا بها في المجر
أم أنها بودابست مرة أخرى وتذوقها
هنا في العاصمة